[Applause]
good afternoon everyone my name is Peter
salave I'm the 23rd president of Yale
University Welcome uh to this historic
uh moment for Yale it's a pleasure and a
and a privilege to have the honor of
introducing a very distinguished visitor
to our campus United Nations Secretary
General Banky
Moon
your Excellency thank you thank you for
coming to Yale and I note that this is
your third such visit and each time you
have inspired our community with your
wise perspective and thank you most
especially for the United Nations and
your personal deep care for the
preservation of cultural heritage and
sponsorship of this important
colloquium when we embarked on our
planning for the events of this week for
the UN Global colloquium of University
presidents itself which will take place
tomorrow and for the wider program of
activities that are taking place
including this public lecture the
response from the Yale Community was one
of immediate and resonant
enthusiasm for our faculty and our
students and our employees and community
members across New Haven the topic at
hand struck a vibrant
chord preservation of cultural cultural
heritage challenges and strategies for
us at yel hosting this year's Global
colloquium there could be no question
that this would be our subject of
focus
why well because quite simply Heritage
matters it is the record both concrete
and intangible
of human
identity when our heritage is
destroyed by war or by weather from
malice or from neglect it is a loss that
in many cases can never be
remedied so we at Yale are delighted to
have the support and cooperation of the
United Nations and the collaboration of
so many individuals across our own
campus and from institutions around the
the world in seeking to protect preserve
and promote our shared cultural
heritage as I said earlier this week's
colloquium and surrounding events have
met with an overwhelming response from
our
community you here in this room today
are a testament to the importance and
the Resonance of our work our work
together more than 15 faculty members
and other experts across the
University from widely varied
backgrounds and diverse fields of study
and practice are contributing not only
to this week's programs but to ongoing
preservation and conservation
efforts I hope that many of you took
advantage of yesterday's open house at
yels West Campus to see the work taking
place at the institute for the
preservation of cultural
heritage if you missed it there's
another open house on Friday and too
many other events to name but you can
read all about them at UNC un uh Global
colloquium unc. yell.edu
Secretary General bun during your last
visit to yel in
2012 you spoke so eloquently of the need
for Collective action to confront the
world's greatest
challenges you called the on us to seek
alliances among
nations among institutions to share the
responsibility for protecting our
world we heard you that day and we felt
the same sense of urgency that you
expressed and I'm very proud to say that
the work you see taking place at Yale
today and with institutional Partners
around the globe is a manifestation of
that belief your Excellency you have
inspired us with your leadership of the
United
Nations you have made important strides
toward
peace you've reached out to nations in
crisis you've worked diligently to
promote the rights of women to protect
the environment and to strengthen the
United Nations and make it more
effective for generations to
come thank you so much for your
leadership in confronting climate change
and fostering sustainability issues on
which Yale shares your deep commitment
you have brought the nations of the
world together achieved concerted and
concrete action with the tremendous
success of cop 21 in Paris as a sign of
real
hope you've also done so much to
encourage young people to participate in
Civic life leading by example as you as
you have engaged with youth listen to
them and help them to find their voices
on the world stage at Yale as Educators
and as committed Global Citizens We're
delighted to have the United Nations as
a partner in supporting the next
generation of Citizen
leaders when it comes to conserving and
preserving cultural heritage and shared
history we at yel like to say the future
of the past is in our hands in all of
our hands and in the hands of every
individual around the world Mr Mr
Secretary General right here and right
now we are in your hands we are eager to
have your insights to learn from your
perspective and to go forth from today
inspired to do even more to contribute
to the vital work that lies
ahead thank you for being with us today
and everyone please join me and giving a
very warm welcome to United Nations
Secretary General Banky moot
thank you distinguish the president
Peter Salo of Yale University
distinguish the Pres of universities
around the world honorable members of
the academic
communities distinguished
faculties dear students ladies and
gentlemen it's a great honor and
pleasure for me to visit the Yale
University again for third time as a
Secretary General and take part in the
United Nations Global
colloquium I'm inspired to be among some
of the most distinguished academics in
the world and to connect your
groundbreaking research with the global
diplomacy of the United
Nations I was energized and
inspired by our previous meetings which
covered maternal Health empowering young
people and harnessing new technologies
uh to meet Global challenges
I'm particularly happy to see so many
young students are here today who will
be surely the leaders of tomorrow but
most of them have already taken the
leadership of today it's important that
for this
colloquium uh to discuss about how we
can how the teachers and professors can
provide good than
sustainable opportunities social
political and economic opportunities for
young
people ladies and gentlemen standing
here as a Secretary General I'm just
thinking of um what will happen after me
as you may know or may not know from
today the selection process of my
successor has begun at the United
Nations
this is going to be very different uh
selection uh
process I'm very happy that there is
going to be a change uh in the United
Nations system there a huge change when
I
was elected as a Secretary General in
2006 I was one of the many candidates
joking me I've been saying that well you
know I'm the first democratically
elected Secretary
General why before me there was no such
Secretary General seven secretaries
generals who were elected through
campaign I was the only one at that time
seven candidates who have been
campaigning in fact I'm very happy uh to
see former president of Mexico zedo
sitting here he was you may
remember I'll tell you all the
secrets I when I was a candidate I was
invited by Davos Forum World economic
Forum uh there were several uh several
candidates that was the first time that
I was having sort of a interview in
front of maybe thousand people president
sedo was moderate
moderator he was giving hard questions
hard
questions I'd like to thank very much
for his vision then he might have
thought that I could be some
possible possible candidate or Secretary
General I think his question was a
little bit softer than other people
other candidates they thank you for that
but for me every question was a
difficult one uh today uh
this this campaign has really began the
in the General Assembly Hall all 193
member states together with the NGO
representatives and they were
questioning the candidates we have four
women four men candidates and these
number of candidate will be will be
increasing in anyway this is a good a
very good way to change this world in a
more transparent more competitive more
accountable way uh accountable way I was
one of them I I think myself I was
elected through that but this process
will be much much more competitive and
much more a transparent one that's a
good for the future of the United
Nations let's
hope for the best and if possible let us
hope that the best candidate could be a
woman candidate uh next from next
year all while what all what I said is
off the Record
today well ladies and
gentlemen I'm
particularly honored to be here and it
is
appropriate that we we are discussing
here at the Yale
where this destruction destruction of
cultural Treasures on a vast scale over
recent years make this our a theme of
this colloquium even more timely and
relevant it's appropriate that we
discussed this here at Yale we the world
famous B library and the institute for
the preservation of cultural
heritage have done so much to raise
awareness of culture in
crisis president Salo I know you have
taken this important course far beyond
the Yale including to to the world
economic Forum at Davos this year where
you devoted Yale's annual event uh to
discussing ancient artifacts from
Babylon and
Palmilla on behalf of the United Nations
I like to thank
you and to express our great admiration
for your commitment to
humanity many distinguished speakers are
here to share their experience on
preserving cultural heritage as a
Secretary General I have been visiting
many historical places where I saw so
many precious Timeless Val
valuable heritages each time whenever I
wrote the guest
book I've been always saying that I'm
very much impressed inspired by what I
have seen today here but these are
common assets of
humanity these should be preserved for
coming Generations so that they will be
inspired this has been my standard
writing all the
times uh today I'd like to put the
preservation of culture into a
geopolitical context to show why we at
the United Nations believe it is
essential to our mission of peace and
security sustainable development and
human rights distinguished University
president dear students ladies and
gentlemen art literature music poetry
architecture these are the Hallmarks of
our human
existence they form a common threat that
unit all civilizations and cultures a
celebration of our emotional lives and
the beauty of our national environment
our cultural
heritage defines our
Humanity cultural
diversity like
biodiversity plays a quantifiable and
crucial part in the health of human
species on Attack on cultural heritage
in our in one part of the world is on
attack on us all on all of us
Humanity but cultural diversity is on
the grave threat around the globe this
is very sad at this time who could fail
to be outraged by the destruction of The
Magnificent Buddhas of
Bia ban the Monument of Palmira the
mosques and cultural artifacts in
Northern Mali
this won vandalism and destruction is
not collateral damage it's a part of a
ruthless wave of cultural and ethnic
cleansing Inseparable from the
prosecution of the communities that
created these cultural gems it's also
part of a cycle of theft and profit that
finances the activities of extremist and
terrorist as a human family we cannot
let them erase our history and
identity any loss of cultural heritage
is a loss of our common
memory it impaires our ability to learn
to build the
experience and to apply the lessons of
the past to the present and the
future culture is also one of the
strongest driving forces for building
societies and imbuing them with values
it knits communities together with a
sense of
community extremist and terrorists have
known this throughout the
ages they have always understood that by
attacking and destroying cultural
artifacts buildings and
ments they can divide the people they
can erase their common values Shred the
S social Fabric and create greater
fragility and vulnerability to their
cynical
ideology in our
response we must even be more determined
to
safeguard and preserve culture than the
extremist are to destroy it this must be
Central to our strategy for tackling
violent extremism and building peace and
restoring
security the United Nations system is
working to strengthen the links between
protection of cultural cultural heritage
peace building missions and humanitarian
emergency
response last last week last Friday in
Geneva I have convened an International
Conference at ministerial level uh to
talk about my plan of action to prevent
the violent
extremism there were
700 people from 120 countries all
participated this was warmly welcomed by
the United Nation general assembly in
February and I'm in the process of
implementing and executing all this plan
of action so that we will be able to
first of all prevent there a violent
extremism it's important that we fight
back and defeat terrorism extremism at
the same time is much more important to
prevent before these things happen once
a terrorist happens terrorist actions
happens it's a cruel and brutal and it's
very tragic but if we can prevent
those extremism and terrorism from
taking place I think that's the way we
can save our human lives and our
cultural artifacts that's very important
Point priority for the United Nations at
this
time ladies and gentlemen I visited
Mali for example in Mali I saw the
destruction caused by extremist
militants to mums and man manuscripts
when they took over Timbuktu in
2012 I visited Mari immediately after
that it was not only about Stones
buildings and papers it was about
identity and human
dignity I will never forget speaking to
the Grand
Imam representatives from the Christian
Community the local governments young
people and women's
Representatives they all said they had
lived together in a diverse Community
for thousand
years they all wanted education jobs and
above all
peace as soon as a Timbuktu was
liberated UNESCO and the Malian
government launched a restoration
operation with logistical support
from the blue helmets of our United
Nations peacekeeping
missions like
destruction restoration is not only
about buildings it is about history
about identity and about culture and the
promise of the future for our succeeding
uh
Generations I'm proud to say that 14
Muslims have now been
completely
the town's people talk about The Rebirth
of
Timbuktu UNESCO stands ready to travel
to
palmir which was liberated just weeks
ago to help evaluate the damage and
protect the city's Priceless cultural
heritage I hope that one day Pala
Aleppo Nev and the other devastated
cities of Syria and Iraq will again
serve as a symbols of unity and
diversity the United Nations security
Council has recognized the important
links between cultural heritage peace
and Security in a landmark resolution
passed last year the security Council
condemned the destruction of cultural
heritage in Iraq and in Syria and
adopted legally binding measures to
combat the illicit trafficking of
Antiquities and cultural artifacts from
these countries this was a rare show of
unity from the security Council which
had been in a deadly deadlock over
Syrian
issues now we must build on these major
steps to advance the cause of Peace
distinguish president uh student ladies
and gentlemen another kind of culture
erupts periodically in some societies
around the cultural touchstones
identities and
beliefs attempts to
persuade can sometimes cross a line into
attempts to shut down differing
opinions University campuses are of at
the center of very heated debate
here too diverse cultures and opinions
are signs of flourishing
Community universities universities
these to be places where we can listen
to each other and each other's ideas in
peace there is nothing more important
than preserving respect for dialogue
debate and yes
disagreement when disrespect is lost
deeper damage can be
done this is the place where professors
teach young generation Young Generation
will some someday will become professors
and leaders of the society this is the
where people learn and
practice I've been speaking to world
leaders whenever and wherever there are
problems and there are many countries
where fires are burning where people are
fighting against their leaders I've been
speaking to these leaders please listen
very carefully
attentively what your people are saying
what their aspirations and challenges
are but sometimes they do not listen to
the voices that's the beginning of the
problems of the country beginning of the
world problem of the world now
in such esteemed educational
institutions like Yale universities and
where you represent around the world
these universities should be the places
to teach your students
how they can listen each other while
exchanging their views they need to
listen to each other's views that's the
basic to mutually understand each other
and then when they become leaders of the
society whether educational political
social economic I think they they have
capacity they have willingness to listen
to each other I know University
presidents are keenly aware of your
responsibility to
Foster such public
dialogue I congratulate you on your
success in staying at the Forefront of
of intellectual Challenge and
change in the internet age universities
need a passionate debate on campus and
to remain relevant I hope the young men
and women here will bring that passion
with you into the world beyond your
studies ladies and
gentlemen the world is at a critical
juncture we need the energy and idealism
of young people to tackle major threats
to human
well-being this world's global
population the half of them is under the
age of
25 that means this year this world is
very young but have we done enough
attention enough education enough for
their job opportunities no I don't think
so that's the beginning beginning of all
these problems which we have therefore
these universities must be the place
where you really educate the good
quality and it's now political leaders
economic leaders Community leaders that
they should employ and Empower these
young
people that's what I'm really going to
discuss with you and another
important issue is how we can address a
climate
change it's not
visible but is impacting
surely whole the spectrums of our life
climate change is an intergenerational
injustice thank you very much for that
the divestment universities when will
you I think we have I know that your
university has has already begun
divestment I am very much grateful for
your leading by example and I I highly
applaud president Salo for his vision
now I can tell you that low carbon
economy is
inevitable it's already happening and it
must be it must be it's
inevitable in even in some of the
wealthiest countries nearly half of
young adults are
unemployed conflict is creating the
highest number of displaced people since
the second world war half of them are
children some 600 million young people
live in countries that are fragile or
War torn the United Nations is
responding to these problems
but we need the engagement of young men
and women to multiply our
efforts all world leaders agreed last
September on the ambitious due 2030
sustainable development
agenda which aim to end first of all
object poverty by
2030 preventable prevented diseases
prevent those people who would otherwise
die from preventable diseases and
Empower women by 2030 our Target of the
United Nations is to make this world 50
to 50 planet Earth where men and women
will have a equal standing in every
aspect of our
life this agenda sustainable development
goals known as sdgs instead of mdgs have
goals which include clear targets for
Education gender equality and decent
work for
all we are now in the first year of
implementation I hope young men and
women will hold governments
accountable for their promises and help
to achieve them and universities and
professors should also be part of
this now first ever World humanitarian
Summit meeting will be held and in
Istanbul next
month this will consider root causes of
conflict and displacement how we can
better protect civilians and how we can
meet the needs of
unprecedented numbers of people who are
moving from here there from conflict
John to the better
places the United Nations will hold the
summit on in September to discuss this
matter I know that many European leaders
are struggling to handle this matter but
it's not the European matters
only there a human tendency that when
there is a conflict then people have to
flee to protect their own lives is a
human tendency that people are moving
from one place to another for better
opportunities it happen since Millen
years many thousand years ago people
were constantly having moving to other
better
places again this is a very important
issue at this
time the climate change sustainable
development goals how we can address
this humanitarian crisis all around the
world can you believe that there are
more than 60 million people around the
world who need immediate assistance
life-saving humanitarian
assistance around the world this is the
most number since the end of second
world
war last December
again the United Nations is making lot
of landmark
decisions when I was talking about this
importance of Youth that for the first
time in the history of the United
Nations I appointed a special Envoy on
youth is a young man but he's now
liasing and networking all around the
world with an youth group and even
Security Council has adopted a landmark
resolution on youth
issues the important significance of the
security Council resolution is that
normally the according to chter of the
United Nations security Council has a
primary responsibility to deal with
International Peace and
security then many people believe that
women issue is
not nothing to do with the peace and
security youth issue has nothing to do
with the peace and security but Security
Council has recognized already 11 years
ago by adopting Landmark resolution
which is open quoted
1325 this is women peace and
security they United Nations recognized
that already lack of gender empowerment
has implications to peace and security
of the world now December last year they
recognized that
youth
issue can have a direct implication to
International Peace and security Now
United Nations is now
addressing comprehensively all all the
issues far too long young people have
been considered good enough to fight
Wars only but not to make
peace this is our commitment United
Nations commitment to address these
issues
finally I hope young people like
yourselves I think you should
lead this campaign to make this world
sustainable more sustainable
environmentally by addressing climate
action Yale sent I know that 100 student
experts to Paris last year when there
was a summit meeting to support hard one
climate change agreement I commend the
Yale for being the first University to
join the carbon pricing leadership
Coalition I have been urging Pension
funds insurance companies and major
companies business companies to start
decarbonizing their portfolios and
shifting towards Greener investment and
student movement and action like a
investment from for
to clean energy that's what we
expect the universities and educational
institutions and particularly our young
leaders should lead this campaign Yale
has shown great leadership in this area
and I commend your
initiatives shareholders are calling on
C companies they invest into to disclose
climate
risk a growing number of corporations
are speaking up in favor of carbon
pricing I encourage Yale to be an even
bigger part of the transition to a safer
healthier low carbon future the path to
Prosperity is clear and we should all do
what we can to put the world on more
sustainable 14 I was very much grateful
while walking to this Auditorium Prince
Salo explained how Yale universities
trying to make carbon low carbon or
management of this and I thank you very
much you you're leading by example I'm
encouraged by the strong political
momentum from more than 130 countries
that have confirmed their intention to
sign this a Paris agreement on
22nd of this
month distinguished
present dear young students ladies and
gentlemen there is a Syrian saying I
quote without the old there is nothing
new without the historical context we
cannot make sense of our world or build
the common future universities have a
critical role in preserving and sharing
knowledge and instilling respect for
cultural heritage and
diversity you are training the next
generation of cultural curators and
leaders academics of all disciplines
know that without open debate research
stagnates and progress slows to a stand
still above all you understand the
critical link between culture and human
development I urge you to lead a global
movement to promote our diverse cultural
heritage for future
Generations engage your colleagues your
friends your students and your teachers
preserving the world's Priceless
cultural heritage is a task for all of
us ladies and gentlemen let us work
together uh to make this world better
for all the people around the world I
thank you for your attention thank you
for your engagement and Leadership thank
you very
much
thank you very much uh thank you
Secretary General Secretary General has
uh agreed to take some questions and uh
I was handed on my way in a stack of 3x5
cards which I presume uh you all uh
filled out earlier uh this
afternoon
um uh and I'll just take them in the
order in which uh uh I received them uh
so this is a question about Palmyra uh
talking about uh how much of it was
destroyed during the
occupation uh of the Islamic State and
one one what you addressed in your talk
the first question is what is the role
of the International Community in
helping to rebuild sites like Palmyra
which you did speak a bit about uh but
the other question uh maybe you could uh
elaborate upon which is what really can
universities do to help with a situation
like
that I think most of you must have read
the newspapers I think it was about two
weeks ago one very brave reporter
visited Palmira at the destruction site
I was appalled to see all this complete
destruction of thousand year
old our cultural heritages
UNESCO and United
Nations when situation improves through
political negotiation when the
security allows us that we will
immediately begin uh to restore as much
as we can
this
Priceless valuable artifacts that's one
commitment which was already announced
by director general of UNESCO
a few weeks ago we will do that then for
that possible the Syrian people uh
should have peace in their homes home
country that's why from Tomorrow the
negotiation is going to
resume in Geneva uh with my uh special
Envoy for Syria uh
chering we've been trying
to make political space as much as
possible and through two meetings we've
been trying
to find out some commonalities
commonalities common elements between
two Waring
parties we have found at least 12 common
elements one of 12 common elements
includes the
Reconstruction of Syria
when there is all the Agreements are
done we can see relative peace and
security so that all these experts can
can enter and engage in reconstruction
social economic reconstruction and
restoration of um cultural heritages
universities you have a very important
role you have produced many many
important political leaders business
Community leaders I think this is the
place where president and prime
ministers and business CEOs and
Educators they are all educated here so
you are the teachers of all the leaders
around the world I think you have a lot
of rich and influence and use your
influence as a
teachers of those political leaders and
business CEO CEOs there is nothing which
one country can
do I think all the hands should be on
the deck but academic institutions
that's the place where we can expect the
most
influence and teaching for those people
that's what and that's why I here I am
here to talk with you thank you thank
you uh this is a question about the
moves from the Middle East and says what
other areas of the world where we where
we should be concerned about what are
the other areas of the world where we
should be cons pres concerned about
preserving cultural heritage in the
future and what could the International
Community do now uh in advance of
conflict uh to build local capacity for
such
preservation I just uh introduced my
experience in timb to Northern Mali a
few years ago when this area was
occupied by all this extremist and
destroyed fortunately we were able with
the United Nations peacekeeping missions
in we were able to liberate the timbuk
to and we as I said UNESCO has restored
all 16 Muslims uh that's one uh good
things it's not only in
Mali we have at least
10 big fires burning places including
Syria Mali Somalia Libya South Sudan
Central African Republic unfortunately
these are all happening in Africa and
Yemen Yemen even though in Yemen since
yesterday the sensation of hostilities
have begun
but it's a very fragile situations are
continuing under these
circumstances when it comes to human
being it's the women and
girls vulnerable group of people who
have been targeted who have been abused
their human rights is now when it comes
to
something then these historical
artifacts they have become
easy targets to erase identity of
certain
religion this is a totally unacceptable
situations
therefore first of all priority is that
we should have a peace restored and we
have to work together how we can make
sure that each and every respects the
other's tradition the others history the
others
culture when my religion my culture is
important the same should be applied to
other people who believes other
religions that their religions and their
culture tradition should also be
respected that's why United Nations has
launched this Alliance of
civilization this is a big initiative
but
still it has not been fully
uh fully able to address this issue it's
very sad we are living in a very uh
difficult era at the same time as I said
it's not only perils or challenges we
have world leaders have given some
strong sense of hope through agenda for
sustainable development targeting 2030
and climate change agreement these two
are
I think the
most most encouraging achievement this
United Nations and International
Community have achieved and presented in
recent years in recent years therefore
while we address
these crisis issues we have to pay more
attention and priority on development
and climate change issues by doing that
we can significantly
reduce the sources of conflict that's my
belief
yes maybe we should turn to uh
sustainability and climate change uh
pick up on a couple of themes in your uh
uh from your talk uh this is a question
uh essentially saying uh what are the
next steps following cup 21 in Paris and
do we need a different approach in the
developed and in the developing
World Cup 21
was is not the end or it's not the
beginning we may say it was a good
beginning but Turning Point very
significant Turning
Point as you may uh know you've been
following
that the negotiation on climate change
has been very slow it took decades
that's why I've
been very emphatically emotionally
stating
that negotiation has been moving at the
snails space snails pace that has been
many
times quoted by media it has been moving
even slower than
snails
last year and since
2014 I have been pushing and
accelerating this pace and during my
time as a Secretary General during the
last 10 years I have convinced at least
three times special Summit meeting on
climate change and my convening
power and
2014 the last meeting before we went to
Paris that was a more most Turning
Point most of the world leaders came and
there were huge show of solidarity by
the people in New York in Manhattan
there were 400,000 people
marched calling for
action and it was not only Manan all
throughout the world that was a turning
point I am very happy that in cop 20 1
this Paris agreement was agreed adopted
by
unanimity it's dramatic and amazing that
out of 196 countries even one country
objects there could not have been any
agreement but all 196 countries agreed
because they know that without taking
action now it will be too late will be
abandon in the moral and political
duties of this world I'm very happy but
this not the end we have to build upon
this one all this agreement should be
implemented without fail that's why one
good thing is that we have deplo
introduced a monitoring and
verifying mechanisms every 5 years years
there will be a monitoring and
verification process it will start from
2018 so first review session will be
held 3 years after from then on every 5
years then we expect the parties member
states would um raise their level of
ambition this ambition level at this
time is
low while we agreed uh to
contain the global temperature rise
below 2° Centigrade but if we continue
like this way then it may end up we may
end up at least 3 degrees then it will
be a tragic tragic situation so we have
to do even lower than 2°
1.5° I think we can do it with the
transformative technology development
and with the low carbon economy with a
sustainable energy deployed I think we
can do it therefore I've been asking
major business Community leaders to
invest in fil in the fossil fuel
Industries to sustainable energy solar
energy wind power and all these
water water hydro hydro Powers these are
the answers and it is
inevitable and it is already taking
place and I'm sure that we will be able
to make it yeah
great if I could uh combine two
questions that came in uh really about
Yale's policies toward um becoming more
sustainable uh Greener campus uh you
mentioned that Yale was the first
University to join the carbon pricing
leadership Coalition which uh the World
Bank and the IMF launched in Paris and
we want to be a laboratory for carbon
pricing uh whether it works to change uh
uh change behavior and what are the
political um constraints and uh issues
that need to be resolved in order to
implement it Beyond a university we've
started here and uh uh so the first
question is do you think experiments of
this kind uh are useful you you did
comment on it a little bit the other one
uh relates to the uh issue that uh uh
some of our students care quite
passionately about and uh uh we're we're
here um making that view uh apparent and
that concerns
divestment uh from uh
investments in companies engaged in uh
extraction or sale of of fossil fuels uh
our chief investment officer has carved
out a strategy that I I believe he may
be the only one doing what he did is he
wrote to all of Yale's fund managers a
letter and our our endowment is is
essentially managed externally by by
fund managers and he encouraged them to
consider the risks of climate change in
their investment
decisions and uh he's about to announce
the results of this letter uh I believe
there's actually going to be an article
in the New York Times tomorrow about
this maybe already online
and what he says is that the results
have been significant in both in terms
of selling past Investments H and uh
refraining from some new ones so this is
kind of an economic based approach uh
rather than wholesale divestment it sort
of um uh approaches it over time as an
investment decision uh over time so the
question is uh whether you think this is
a useful way to move the global economy
toward toward uh greater use of clean
energy
technology my my answer is of course
definitely it's a very
commendable very good um initiative and
normally one may think that climate
change or sustainable development and
that's what government leaders do or
that's what business communities will
have to
do but
universities and educational
institutions are no
exception in that regard I was so happy
to I'm so happy to hear that Yale
universities is really leading by
example when you
teach you have to lead you have to
practice what my role sometimes as a
Secretary General is a lot of
preaching when you just preach and if
you don't do it it's not fair you have
to do as you
preach you have to do as you
teach this is what you are
showing and I believe that what your
Chief Financial Officer has been doing
with all these business communities
dealing with the universities I think
that's a fantastic idea
and this this may sound a small
initiative I hope that the presence
of who are participating here uh should
uh emulate and when you return your
University should also do uh the exactly
what uh Yale universities is doing at
the same time I appreciate some of the
student who stood up with the
banners when you implement this
clim climate change and sustainable
development goals and sometimes you need
activism we normally think that activism
is for what the NOS or civil societies
and business CEOs government officials
are always a
defensive they always try to say
something than
defensive it's only the Civil Society
and NOS who really provoke and Challenge
and motivate government officials and
business communities I really appreciate
your
activism I'm asking young
students you may even challenge your
professors you May challenge
your Congressman senators and
president you have that
prerogative
because you have a fresh idea
and creative
ideas then most of all this is the world
where you will have to
live I'm you know my term ends December
this year so I'll become a just a normal
Citizen and professors one day president
one day you may retire then that's your
your place it will be your place and
therefore you have a legitimate right to
challenge your community and leaders
that look Professor Senators Mr
President this is my world this is the
place where I I will have to leave my
children will have to leave please make
this world
sustainable economically
social as a final question uh one that's
a little bit more uh
self-reflective uh and that is about you
uh January as you said will Mark 10
years as un Secretary General and the
completion of your second
term and this question asks what
Leadership
Lessons
uh have you learned in this 10 years and
in particular what are the challenges
for the UN of the future and are there
any Leadership Lessons that our students
can take away from your experience uh uh
at the UN that's um a little Pro prod
question which is a very difficult I
think the leadership when you talk about
leadership I don't think there is any
clearcut definition of a leadership that
should be be different from where uh
what kind of profession where you are
placed in but my
leadership as a Secretary General or
senior Public Public Service
servant should always be
listening
listening uh to the voices of the people
that what can I do for them what they
are really thinking what are their
aspirations are what are their concerns
and challenges are this is what I have
been doing then often I've been saying
that I'm a defender of defenseless
people I am a voice of voiceless people
there are many people you will be
surprised to know that there are many
voiceless people many vulnerable group
of people who are completely defenseless
where and when their human rights and
human dignity are
just ruthlessly abused then I've been
speaking out for them I've been speaking
out for them this is one aspect of
leadership but when
you lead your long life 70 years or 8
years I often say
that the highest virtue
of a human being is to look act like
water this is what I talk to President
Obama and one day I wrote some
calligraphy and gave this to President
Obama Mr President I think your
leadership looks like
water
water I believe in and I hope if anybody
agrees with my points please try to
practice but it's not easy it's not easy
water seems to be just a powerless
weakest no power nothing but
water is very powerful when it has to
when it definitely has to be there are
many important elements in our world
there are some fiery people very dynamic
leadership who speaks a fiery and very
eloquently but do they really practice
do they really know how to make a
compromise and some flexible
flexibility this is what I have seen
among so many leaders they are seemingly
very Dynamic but do not know how to make
some
harmonious decision harmonious
conclusion of a
debate if you just insist your
views suppose you may be
right but that's not the end you may you
cannot be 100% right all the times there
is always some good point to listen to
others views and make the other's views
as yours and combine it make it
harmonious
when I believe in this um theory of
water the highest virtue is to act like
water you don't need to always to
confront when there is a something
Hazard and then you may you know avoid
all this unnecessary you don't need to
confront all the times but when it is
absolutely necessary you can push
you can really push hard this is what we
see from
water water doesn't have color water
doesn't have any order water doesn't
seemingly doesn't have any power but in
the end it can win over anything can
fire win over water everybody believes
that fire is a has a deadly force but is
water to
extinguish and
still even still cannot win over water
wood Earth or whatever in our life in
that regard if you believe in that if
you act like water I'm sure that you
will be respected by all the people
around you that's my belief but it's up
to you thank
you
[Music]
I want to uh I want to thank all of you
for coming uh today and especially to uh
those of you who submitted questions and
uh want to thank you for an excellent
address and for taking those questions
Kam Sam thank you very
[Applause]
much